[Music]
Philip has been talking like this for
decades now and the fact is he keeps
writing books and people keep reading
them and and I I just I disagree
strenuously human beings need stories
and we're looking for them in all kinds
of places whether it's television
whether it's comic books or movies or
radio plays whatever whatever form
people are hungry for stories children
I mean think of your own childhood how
important the bedtime story was so
important these imaginary experiences
were for you they helped shape reality
and I think human beings I wouldn't be
human without narrative fiction okay
perhaps you know the market the way the
way things are moving fewer people are
reading novels than than previously but
still if you walk into a bookstore there
are thousands upon thousands of them
there and they wouldn't be in print
unless somebody was buying them
libraries are cramped with novels as
well and people are reading them and I
don't think it's ever going to dry up
because to the novel is such a flexible
form it's not like a sonnet it's not
fixed you can do anything you want with
it it's just a story that you tell
within the covers of a book but all all
bets are off there are no rules and and
that's why I think the novel is
constantly reinventing itself and
society continues to reinvent itself
every historical moment needs the
stories to be told about it so much as I
admire Philip Roth I I just think he's
wrong about this
well I know it's changing already or at
least there are new things that have
been happening but it even goes back 10
20 years now
hypertext Bob Hoover doing all these
things with computers and multiple
narrators of stories multiple authors of
stories I should say I don't know I
don't know I'm not a man deeply
interested in technology it eludes me
I confess I don't even have a computer I
don't have a cell phone but I did read
recently about a new digital magazine
doing very short stories that people can
read on their telephones maybe this is
interesting maybe not I think people are
trying out ideas with the new technology
and it's too early to say where it's
going exactly but but again whether it's
digital or paper it doesn't matter it's
words that somebody is reading and
getting an experience out of that
reading that's that's all that really
matters
[Music]